you recommend a particular store or pharmacy to purchase safe
ivermectin. i've been getting my supply from a place in
india that is recommended to me by a good friend who's a pharmacist.
she said a lot of our medication from the US
thumbs from india. this particular place is a good customer service so
they seem reputable however in recent weeks i've been
reading more about how ivermectin can be contaminated with the
various elements like mRNA.
have it only knows if that is true because there is so much
consecutive information in the line. do you think it'd be worth it to have a
supply tested for purity or is that overkill?
well i think it would be worth it to have a supply tested for purity. i just don't
know how you could do that unless you're old-year-old biocamalam.
so i know that's just not to be real doable.
but the first question i do not have a particular store or pharmacy that i
have ordered ivermectin from because i don't have i have not used ivermectin.
do i have a supply of men's at home in case of a catastrophe? yes
um and is ivermectin part of that supply? yes but there's not a lot of capsules in my
supply i don't know but i don't want it i don't even know what it is i don't even
look at it with a kid from that wellness store or something like that i'm
where i got it. so place of life. have i heard that uh
ivermectin has been tainted with different things? yes i've heard that same thing.
do i believe that it's true? well i don't know i don't know if that's true um
but i would say i would doubt it. so remember what i've always said is
ivermectin is still a drug so you know it still has side effects even if it
isn't tainted with something. firstly i don't trust the pharmaceutical companies as far as
i could throw up and i would agree that it could be tainted with the various elements.
it's that i just don't know and i don't know how we would know that.
i wish i had a better answer for you.